Let's draw a
rectangle we draw the same rectangle
divided into five equal regions like this If
this is the whole rectangle then each of these are called its
parts Each box in here
is a part Now let us represent one
part of this figure by coloring it red  This
Becomes A Part Of The
Say That It Is A Part Of The Whole And In
Mathematics We Write It As 1/5 And 1 / 5 This
Means That We Are Considering One Part
Out Of The Five Parts A Part Of The Whole Now Let's
Color  Three parts out of the
five This one This one and This one Three
parts out of the total Five are colored Since this
is represented as 3/5 These two are called
fractions There is one number
on top and one at the bottom The number on top  Is
called the numeration and the number at the bottom is
the
denominator You can see the numeration as the
number of parts you have colored and the
denominator is the number of parts The whole is
divided into a good way to remember This is what ever
is down  What is the denominator d and
d and what kind of fraction in which the
numeration is less than the denominator are called proper
fractions what if all the parts are colored will it be a
proper fraction can the
numeration be more than the
denominator we will answer all these  Questions
in the Next
[Music]
Video